[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben zum ersten mal ramadan
reihe gibt es heute auf einem kanal
etwas diese ich habe hier abwechselnd
arabischen mit pudding aufgeschichtet
karossen der preise faden nudeln die ist
man in der orientalischen küche immer
als dessert
wir benötigen 200 gramm katalog findet
in jedem türkischen supermarkt 70 gramm
butter 30 gramm puderzucker das hoffen
wir für die erste schicht und hier ist
noch wichtig zu sagen dass man finca
tarif dsl englisch in der form die muss
man dann mit dem nachmieter hand in
stücke reißen
für die zweite schicht also den
arabischen mit pudding benötigen wir 900
familie 80 gramm speisestärke 60 gramm
puderzucker und einen esslöffel
orangenblüten satz auf dem würde ich
auch nicht verzichten denn erst dann
habt ihr den typisch orientalischen
geschmack erstes bereiten wir die phasen
nudeln zu dafür nehmen wir unsere butter
geben ihnen einen topf erhitzen sie und
geben anschließend inka grings dies wird
dann solange angebraten bis die
gewünschte bräune erreicht
ich empfehle euch allerdings nicht die
höchste stufe einer kochplatte zu
verwenden denn es kann sein dass es sehr
schnell an grant also behaltet es immer
im auge und rührt dabei ständig um
[Musik]
sobald der kater es dann eine schöne
braune farbe angenommen hat kann auch
schon der puderzucker mit hinzu der wird
dann einmal kurz unter kuriert und dann
schmeckt er auch schon wie von alleine
diese schicht ist nun fertig und kann
bis zur weiterverarbeitung zur seite
gelegt werden für den leckeren
milchprodukte milch in den topf geben
anschließend die speisestärke hinzu
gegeben und alles glatt gehört wichtig
ist dass behält jetzt noch nicht
eingeschaltet wird insofern sie die
zutaten besser vermischen
jetzt gehen wir noch den puderzucker
hinzu und verrühren das gut miteinander
lassen
nun kann auch die kochplatte
eingeschaltet werden
jetzt ist es wichtig dass ihr während
das ganze auf kocht immer rührt und das
ganze nie aus den augen lässt
sobald die mischung dann ein mal
aufgekocht wurde liegt mir auch schon
ein gegeben dann das orangenblüten
wasser hinzu und früheren das noch mal
kurz
weil man immer denkt immer wieder trotz
sorgfältiger berühren kleine klümpchen
habt gebe ich das ganze noch mal durch
ein beben für dieses rezept empfehle ich
euch generell den pudding noch warm in
europa einzuführen weil es sonst einfach
nicht so richtig funktioniert wenn er
fest ist wenn ihr den aber noch lagern
möchte dann macht auf jeden fall
frischhaltefolie drauf und zwar direkt
an der oberfläche
anschließend wird das ganze in euer
lieblings glas gefüllt und geschichtet
und da könnt ihr selber entscheiden was
sie als erstes nimmt kabel käfig
entschieden gebe darüber dann die
leckere milchzähne und dann eben immer
so weiter bis das glas auch schön voll
ist
hier habe ich noch mal mit einem löffel
den milchpolitik zurechtgerückt damit
dass auch von außen für die optischen
aus
[Musik]
sobald die gläser dann schön gefüllt
sind kann ich das ganze noch mit
leckeren pistazien wer möchte kann aber
auch schokolade statt besten nehmen oder
frische früchte das ist auch mal sehr
schön anzusehen bitte die leckeren
buffet serviert gibt da am besten
frischhaltefolie drauf und lage ist den
kühlschrank so kann das ganze noch mal
schön fest werden und dann wünsche ich
euch ganz viel spaß beim genießen
bei diesem bisher hat man nicht gleich
das gefühl dass man auf zucker bei ist
denn es ist wirklich sehr mild und durch
der orangenblüten wasser habt ihr auch
diesen orientalischen geschmack ich
freue mich wenn die übermorgen zu meinem
nächsten video auch wieder dabei sein
bis zum nächsten mal auf die skizzen
[Musik]